I was leaving behind the different
smells and the sounds of this ship and I
entered a completely different world
I always felt a direct connection to
Nature and to just a mixture of colors
also around me it's all different shapes
of blue and white
[Music]
physicist at The alphabetic Institute in
Prima I'm studying the CI that is the
Frozen part of the ocean
my research field is all about the ice
thickness actually how the ice is
getting thicker and thinner again
[Music]
the typical Expedition day starts first
of all with a lot of planning because
security is really an important aspect
so we first make sure that we have the
right equipment on us so that we are
protected against the cold and also
against the water and yeah with all that
equipment and with your Sledge You're
Gonna Leave the boat then walking down
the gangway you feel maybe the winds and
of course the colds and then when you
start to walk I would say the first
thing you hear is this um yeah noise of
walking on ice and snow
most people think of the Arctic as a
really quiet and flat plane of ice but
it's actually not at all so it's always
in motion first of all the whole ice is
in motion and the ice normally drifts in
yeah in the time frame of about a year
from the Siberian Arctic towards Europe
and is then leaving after the Arctic
there so for first of all that is motion
and within that motion there is also
some differential motion so it's not
always going uniformly in One Direction
but we have here areas where we have
this converging eyes flows and diverging
ice flows again where we have then the
sea ice ridges and leads forming and
that is also not quiet but you can
actually hear those deformation
processes because this breaking ice
makes a lot of sound and then also yeah
when ice flows are moving on top of each
other it's like this cracking sound and
that's actually quite impressive
foreign
due to the ice Dynamics we realized that
that it is not stable at all and that
maybe one day could be enough to to yeah
really move all equipment that was
located in in Matt town that was for the
atmospheric measurements
um just a kilometer to the other side if
you then see how power lines are catch
our instruments are almost drowning then
you you really realize that this is not
just your neighborhood in front of
somewhere else here here in Europe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so my research field is all about the
ice thickness actually and I'm very
interested in the physical processes so
there are two processes that make sea
ice thicker the first one is just
thermodynamics that's the freezing of
your eyes it's a bit like what happens
in a freezer and then there's a second
process that is more specific to the to
the sea ice and that is the Dynamics so
CI is deformation and that means all the
processes where sea ice is for example
colliding so when we have ice flows that
are colliding then are breaking and
pushing eyes below and on top of each
other and building up CIS riches so that
has of course a big impact on the
thickness and there's also the opposite
taking place when the sea ice flows
diverge then we form one of those sea
ice leads we call it it's just an area
of Open Water a stripe of open water and
those processes are yeah at the center
of my research Focus
foreign
research shows that the sea ice extent
decline that we observe now in the
Arctic that this is a reversible process
so it's not all lost and even though
we're expecting Arctic the Summers
without sea ice or with just really
little sea ice we can still change that
so if we really commit us now to to um
yeah climate protection measurements as
a society then I'm pretty sure that
we're gonna also witness again more sea
ice in the Arctic
[Music]